.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ein Lauf, ein Gang
in etwas Unbekanntes.
Das hatten wir lange nicht mehr.
Grüezi, wir sind Jonny ...
... und Manu
vom Cabaret DivertiMento.
Als Komiker haben wir
schon viel zusammen erlebt.
Aber so etwas wie hier? Nein!
Es ist auf jeden Fall härter
als wir gedacht haben.
Es hört nicht auf.
Drei Wochen, 150 km zu Fuss
durch die schottischen Highlands.
Eine Reise weitab vom Schuss,
nur wir zwei ganz alleine.
Das Ziel dieser Reise ist, dass wir
uns wieder etwas näherkommen.
Dass die Freundschaft
wieder menschlicher wird
und weniger beruflich.
Nach einer Woche wandern
sind wir schon richtig
in das Schottland eingetaucht.
Es sieht zwar fröhlich aus, ...
... aber wir
haben wieder Sachen erlebt ...
... die uns gelernt haben,
zu beissen.
Das ist
"SRF bi de Lüt - Durch dick ...
... und dünn."
* Drollige Klänge *
Das ist unser Hotel, mitten im Wald
am Loch Lomond in Schottland.
Also es war etwas rudimentär,
eine unbewartete Schutzhütte.
So haben wir in Schottland
unsere vierte Nacht verbracht.
Bis hierher sind wir schon
recht weit gewandert, ca. 35 km.
Ich war etwas abgekämpft
und hatte v.a. kalt.
Ich komme noch nicht raus.
Bleib weiterhin in deinem Wurm!
Hast du gut geschlafen?
Es war tipptopp.
Viel besser als im Zelt.
Das ist so.
Es war also de luxe
im Gegensatz zum Zelt.
Wirklich.
Komm jetzt, aufstehen!
Du mit deinen
sexy langen Unterhosen!
Hör auf!
Ich gehe
und mache Spiegeleier und Speck.
Ich hätte lieber ein Continental.
Vielleicht etwas Lachs,
gerne etwas Lachs?
Super und ein Schlückchen Prosecco.
Ja, den hole ich gleich im Keller.
Ah!
Ich finde es einfach kalt.
Schön wäre es gewesen
mit dem Frühstück,
aber der nächste Laden
ist 18 km entfernt von hier.
Meine Linsen sind verklebt.
Ein Müesli hat auch gereicht
und los sind wir.
Aber zuerst
hatten wir noch eine Mission.
Rufen wir noch ...
- Let's calling Mike!  - Yes.
Ich habe irgendwo
seine Telefonnummer.
Mike ist ein Schweizer, der hier
lebt und Fischertouren anbietet.
Für mich als Hobbyfischer
ein gefundenes Fressen.
5,9 ...
- 7,5,9,1,0,9,9.
Vielleicht hat er keinen Empfang.
- Das kann sein.
Mike speaking!
Hallo, Mike! Hier sind
Jonny und Manu von "SRF bi de Lüt".
Hallo, miteinander!
Guten Morgen.
Finden wir dich, wenn wir
auf dem Weg in dieses Kaff gehen?
Wo bist du dort?
Ich bin auf dem Parkplatz
in Inversnaid.
Okay, das ist perfekt.
Wir freuen uns sehr
und gehen nun los.
Super, dann sehe wir uns in
ca. 1 1/2 Std. in Inversnaid.
Super, ich freue mich.
Tschüss! - Ich mich auch.
Tschüss, miteinander!
Der hört sich easy an.
- Total schweizerisch.
Seine Art, wie er gesprochen hat:
"This is speaking Mike."
"Ah, hallo, miteinander!"
"Es ist grossartig ..."
Es war sehr lustig.
Schön, man versteht jemanden
wieder einmal richtig.
Ich freue mich. Also, 1 1/2 Std.,
das Essen ist organisiert.
Let's go!
Los geht's! 1 1/2 Std. oder ca. 7 km
sind es von unserer Waldhütte
bis nach Inversnaid,
zu Mike, unserem Schweizer Fischer.
* "Off The Hook"
von Hardwell und Armin van Buuren. *
Der Weg ist immer schön
am Loch Lomond entlang -
wandern mit Aussicht.
* "Off The Hook"
von Hardwell und Armin van Buuren. *
Tag ...
- Kleine Augen.
Ja, ja, kleine Augen.
In dieser Waldhütte geschlafen ...
Tag wie viel haben wir? Fünf?
Für dich sechs, für mich fünf.
Tag fünf -
wir sind eigentlich noch recht fit.
Ich glaube, den Fischer
drückt an einer Stelle der Schuh.
Meine Waden brennen etwas,
aber sonst sind wir fit,
nicht wahr, Fischer?
Ja, wir sind seit fünf Tagen in
diesem Schottland oben am Wandern.
Gestartet sind wir in Glasgow.
Von hier geht der West Highland Way
150 km in den Norden
bis nach Fort William.
Etwa einen Drittel des ganzen Weges
haben wir geschafft.
Wir hatten also
noch ein wenig vor uns.
* "Off The Hook"
von Hardwell und Armin van Buuren. *
Wir haben uns
die ganze Zeit gefragt:
"Wer ist wohl dieser Mike,
unser Schweizer Fischer?"
Ich bin extrem gespannt, wie er
aussieht und warum er hier lebt.
Ich glaube, er ist 42,
hat eine hohe Stirn,
blonde Haare,
das hat man an der Stimme gehört.
* Beschwingte Musik *
* "King Of The Road"
von The Proclaimers *
Der Loch Lomond
ist bekannt als Fischgewässer.
Aber Mike
hatte mit uns andere Pläne.
Irgendwo hier in den Hügeln hat er
einen eigenen See, den Loch Katrine.
Nach ca. 7 km begann es zu rauschen.
Das ist
der Wasserfall von Inversnaid.
Hier treffen wir Mike.
Endlich einmal
ein richtiger Wasserfall.
Ich war ja gespannt, ob Jonny
in Sachen Haarfarbe richtig lag.
Kurzgeschoren! Dort unten ist er.
Wo?
- Dort.
Das ist er.
Der mit der Sonnenbrille.
Weisst du das?
Ich spüre es.
Mit der Frisur
sind wir extrem nah dran.
Michael!
Hallo!
Hallo, ich heisse Jonny!
Hallo, Jonny!
Manu! - Hallo, Manu! Freut mich.
Anhand deiner Stimme hast du
die gleiche Frisur wie ich.
" Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Es ist mega schön, dass wir
wieder jemanden gut verstehen.
Hattet ihr etwas Mühe?
Der Akzent ist so schwierig
zu verstehen. Verstehst du alles?
Ja, in der Zwischenzeit schon.
Mike ist Glarner,
lebt aber schon lange in Schottland.
Hier hat er einen See gepachtet
und bietet Fischereitouren an.
Fängt man hier überhaupt etwas?
Mir stinkt es, wenn ich stundenlang
an einem See sitze und nichts fange.
Und die zwei, die ich habe,
muss ich wieder reinwerfen.
Die Chancen stehen heute relativ
gut, dass wir etwas fangen.
Ich sitze extrem gerne am Wasser.
Ich habe schon ein paarmal gesehen,
wie viel Geduld Manu hat.
Geduld brauchen wir keine.
- Bei dir?
Ich sage jetzt nicht allzu viel.
Das Ziel von heute wäre, dass wir
einen Hecht fangen - über 1 m lang.
Das wäre eigentlich das Ziel.
Einen Hecht - über 1 m lang!
- Ja.
Ich hoffe,
dass wir etwas herausholen.
Mega.
- Gehen wir! Sorry, aber er drückt.
Gehen wir entladen.
1 m lang - das glaubst du ja nicht!
Mike's See ist ein paar Kilometer
neben dem Loch Lomond.
Und damit auch neben unserem
Wanderweg, dem West Highland Way.
Es war also ein Abstecher
und Mike hat uns chauffiert.
(Kameramann) Moment, der Ton ist
noch auf dem Mischer. Autofahrt!
Klappe!
Ja, halt doch selbst die Klappe!
Ja, ein konstruktiver Kommentar
von Herrn Fischer!
Was wir schnell
herausgefunden haben:
Mike fährt wie
ein richtiger Schotte, d.h. schnell.
Sehr schnell.
Kein Wunder, er lebt ja schon seit
14 Jahren mit seiner dänischen Frau
hier in Schottland.
Du bist ja schon lange hier
und sie ist aus Dänemark.
Ihr habt euch aber
nicht hier kennengelernt?
Nein, wir haben uns
in Thailand kennengelernt. - Was!
Ja, in Thailand vor ...
... im nächsten März vor 20 Jahren.
Wow, da warst du ja sehr jung.
Ja, ich war mega jung. Ich war 19.
Autofahren mit Mike ist, wie gesagt,
eine rasante Angelegenheit.
Nach 15 Min. sind wir am See ...
- Hey, sie sagen Loch.
... ah, genau, am Loch Katrine
angekommen., Mike's See.
Dieser See
ist etwa so gross wie der Walensee -
eben Loch Walen.
Ich liebe es.
Mike ist ein sehr spannender Typ.
Was wir machen dürfen,
ist auch sehr aussergewöhnlich.
Logisch, kein Fischer verspricht dir
jemals, dass du heute etwas fängst,
aber er sagt,
die Chancen seien gross.
Und scheinbar hat es andere Kaliber
als bei uns in der Schweiz.
Er ist heute mit uns auf Hechte aus.
Die sind 1 m lang, wenn nicht mehr.
Da erfreut sich
mein Fischerherzchen extrem.
Und ich finde es okay.
Aber es ist schön,
dass du mitkommst.
Absolut. Nein, ich freue mich
jetzt auch ... äh ...
Du hast auch Freude.
- ... etwas mit dir zu teilen.
Ich kenne das nicht. Ich esse
ab und zu ein Fischstäbchen.
Mike hat eine bewegte Biografie.
Er ist gelernter Maurer,
hat eine Zeit lang in der Schweiz
als Berufsmilitär gearbeitet,
und ist dann ausgewandert.
In Schottland hat er sein Hobby
fischen quasi zum Beruf gemacht.
Dazu hat er noch
Aquakultur studiert.
Das ist die Wissenschaft über alles,
was im Wasser gezüchtet werden kann.
Er ist eigentlich ein Wasser-Bauer.
Als ich das letzte Mal fischte,
hätte ich mich gefreut,
wenn ich einen so
grossen gefangen hätte.
Das ist einer der kleineren Köder.
Normalerweise haben wir grössere.
Es ist wirklich so, die Grösse
der Köder haben die Grösse,
wenn nicht grösser, als das,
was ich aus den Bächen ziehe.
Unglaublich!
Er hat Köder von Fischarten,
die hier nicht vorkommen.
Das ist dem Hecht aber egal.
Man fischt hier tatsächlich
etwas anders als in der Schweiz.
Das Töten des Fisches
ist in Schottland nämlich verpönt.
Man fängt ihn
und lässt ihn dann wieder frei.
Catch and release heisst das.
Darum brauchen die Fischer
keinen Widerhaken
und haben Netze und Matten, um
den Fisch schonend herauszuziehen.
Es ist sehr spannend - bis jetzt.
Ein Gedränge auf dem Begleitboot.
Knall mir den Fisch
nicht um die Ohren!
Der tropft etwas.
- Ja, und es gibt ein Wirrwarr.
Das ist eine ernste Angelegenheit.
* Sanfte, majestätische Musik *
Ich sehe, wo die anderen sind.
In der Schweiz
fische ich ab und zu im Bach,
aber das hier
war schon eine andere Liga.
Ja, Manu hatte Freude und mir ging
es so wie erwartet:
Wir hocken auf dem Boot
und nichts passiert.
Aber irgendwie
hat es mir doch noch gefallen.
Das ging daneben.
* Jonny lacht. *
Ja, da hat der Fischer Freude.
Hey, verschwinde!
Super, perfekt,
ein absolut perfekter Wurf!
Du musst noch den Bügel rüber legen.
Mike wollte es echt wissen:
Wir haben satte acht Ruten gesetzt.
Ich habe ja nicht daran geglaubt,
aber plötzlich ...
Mein Gott!
- Nein, er ist draussen.
Scheisse!
Warte, jetzt geht dieser Fisch ab.
Das war ein Wahnsinnskick!
Nur warten! Das ist
wahrscheinlich ein grosser Fisch.
Immer auf Spannung gehen!
Merkt er noch nicht,
dass er dran ist? - Nein.
Hast du gesehen,
wie er gerissen hat?
Wenn er das erste Mal hochkommt,
siehst du ihn.
Schön auf dieser Seite behalten!
Hier behalten, hier behalten!
Wie gross ist das Viech?
Einiges über 1 m.
Hier behalten, hier behalten!
Zum Zeugs raushalten!
Hier behalten! Schön.
Kontrollieren, kontrollieren!
Jetzt geht er ab wie ein Schwein.
Scheisse,
schau wie gross das Viech ist!
Wow, Scheisse!
Ui, ui, ui, ich fluche ich viel
vor lauter Freude.
Und ich war etwas überfordert.
Raufnehmen! Jawohl. Herannehmen!
Cool, der ist im Netz.
Scheisse! Wow, Scheisse!
Schau dir das an!
Schau dir das an.
Wow, Scheisse!
Oh, krass!
Schau dir das an!
Was wiegt der?
Weit über 20 Pfund,
weit über 20 Pfund.
Das ich das einmal erleben darf,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Unglaublich!
20 Pfund.
Das läuft doch schon fast ein wenig
unter: Das Ungeheuer von Loch Ness.
Ich kapiere nicht, warum er
nicht zappelt wie verrückt.
Warum hat keine Panik?
Weil ich ihn ganz ruhig behandle.
So macht es ihm nichts aus.
Der Fisch ist nicht verletzt,
der Haken macht ihm nichts.
Genau so, Jungs.
Man spürt ja den Puls.
Aber etwas grusig ist er schon.
Ich finde ihn den Hammer.
Hey, danke, Mike!
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Man hört wie er pulsiert.
Dieser arme Kerl.
Ich kapiere nicht,
dass er so ruhig ist.
Das ändert sich,
wenn ihr ihn wieder zurück tut.
24 Pfund.
1,10 m.
Wahnsinn!
- Ein schottischer Hecht.
Der Chef
hatte mind. so viel Freude wie wir.
Jetzt unterstützt man ihn
hier ganz leicht.
* Heroische Musik *
Wow!
Wahnsinn!
Vielen Dank. Das war so geil!
Vor anderthalb Jahren hat mich hier
einer erwischt. - Fisch!
Ja, schön kontrollieren!
Fischer
hat einen Hecht an der Angel.
Wer hätte das gedacht.
Er hat extremen Zug, nicht wahr?
- Extremen Zug.
Scheisse!
- Hier ist er.
Achtung!
Gut, zieh ihn hinüber!
Er kämpft jetzt auch.
Ich bin überwältigt.
Der absolute Hammer-Moment.
Jetzt kannst du mir
etwas Schnur geben.
Schaue diese Zähne! - So ein Zahn
ist messerscharf, oder?
Die möchte ich nicht erwischen.
Nein, hör auf!
Ich habe keine Freudentränen,
die sind vom Wind.
Aber es war krass.
Ich musste sehr fest atmen.
Ja, du musstest fest ziehen.
Es sind richtige Fische
und das nach 15 Min.
So ist fischen schon geil.
Der Hammer!
Hey!
Wahnsinn!
Der Haken kommt extrem
leicht heraus, kaum Blut.
Ich fand es eindrücklich,
ihn zu streicheln.
Wie ein Haustier.
Und dann lässt man sie
sanft wieder hinein.
Es ist sicher kein Vergnügen
für den Fisch,
aber das Trauma
hat er bald verarbeitet.
Ich denke auch. Es war geil.
Bombastisch!
- Sehr, sehr geil!
Jetzt noch
das Blut von den Händen waschen.
Tja, zwei Hechte an
einem Nachmittag - nicht schlecht.
Mike hat für unsere Übernachtung
etwas organisiert, etwas Spezielles,
ein historisches Anwesen
direkt am See.
Hm, nach der letzten Nacht
in der Baracke im Wald
war unser Bedarf an alten Hütten
eigentlich gedeckt.
Aber Mike führte uns
zu einem kleinen Palast.
Das soll
das Geburtshaus von Rob Roy sein.
Der ist so etwas
wie der schottische Wilhelm Tell.
Das ist nicht Rob Roy,
sondern Ian Gordon.
Ihm und seiner Frau Sheila
gehört dieses Haus.
Es ist kein Bed and Breakfest.
Wir konnten hier übernachten,
weil Mike die beiden gut kennt.
Schau dir das an!
Wenn du hier in der Badewanne
liegst, schau dir diese Aussicht an!
Ja, jetzt ist es blöd,
weil du im Spiegel bist.
Hier siehst du den Berg, den See -
ein Traum!
So geil!
Jetzt noch einen Kaffee
oder einen Tee - grossartig.
Oh, ist das schön.
Das ist für mich nicht Schottland,
das ist das Paradies.
Voll geil!
Du hast den längeren Fisch als ich,
also herausgezogen.
Darum darfst du sagen,
wer wo schläft.
* Manu spricht unverständlich. *
So, komm jetzt!
Komm!
Vielen Dank.
Also, komm raus!
Wir haben uns mit Mike noch
für den nächsten Tag verabredet.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
- Ich werde heute Nacht träumen.
Hoffentlich nicht von mir.
Es war einzigartig.
Was für ein Erlebnis.
Morgens um wie viel Uhr?
- Ich komme gegen 8.30 Uhr.
Ich hole euch dann ab.
* Dynamische Gitarrenklänge *
Hier hat alles gepasst. Wir haben
in einem Schloss geschlafen.
Es war zwar Vollmond
und ich reagiere auf Vollmond,
darum war ich nachts ab und zu wach.
Aber es war ein Traum.
Draussen der See, der Mond,
und dann fing es an zu regnen.
Es war echt ein Traum.
Das erste Mal alleine im Zimmer
war auch schön.
Ich fand es so spannend,
nur einen kurzen Moment in das Leben
von fremden Leuten zu schauen.
Wir wurden heute Morgen zum
Frühstück eingeladen - unerwartet.
Und dann nur ein paar Worte mit
wildfremden Leuten zu wechseln ...
Das ist etwas, was mir
auf dieser Reise sehr viel gibt.
Mich ein Stück weit auch befriedigt.
Vielleicht hat es
etwas mit Voyeurismus zu tun.
Man sieht eben in das Haus,
in das Leben von fremden Leuten.
Das ist etwas mega Spannendes.
Zackig wie immer
ist dann Mike vorgefahren.
Heute erwartet uns
irgendetwas typisch Schottisches.
Ich nehme an,
es geht vom musikalischen
bis in den sportlichen Bereich.
Es kann sein,
dass sie es mega lustig finden,
wenn wir am morgen betrunken
irgendwelche Spiele machen müssen.
Das hoffe ich nicht.
Es kann auch sein,
dass wir einen Einblick
in alte, schottische Traditionen
bekommen.
Ich würde mega gerne einmal
einen Kilt anziehen.
Ich hoffe, heute kann ich das tun.
Hu, wenn ich dann
schon gewusst hätte ...
Ich glaube, wir wären
nicht bei Mike eingestiegen.
Mike, was erwartet uns hier?
Jetzt darfst du es uns sagen.
Als nächstes gehen wir
auf die Leddard Farm.
Dort werden wir zuerst
Tontaubenschiessen.
Ha, geil!
Schiessen ist gut. Hier hat uns Mike
fast selber abgeschossen.
Da hatte ich fast einen Herzanfall!
Zum Glück ging alles gut
und wir kamen nach 30 Min.
auf der Leddard Farm an.
Mitten im schottischen Nirgendwo.
Die Farm gehört Familie Wood.
Hello!
- Hello! Nice to meet you.
Extra für die Kamera.
Das ist Gregor
und dann kommt sein Vater Fergus.
Erster Programmpunkt:
Tontaubenschiessen!
Komm!
This is Johnson McFischer.
Ich werde frühmorgens
nicht so gerne gefilmt.
Am Schluss
gibt es sicher eine Challenge.
Jetzt haben wir eine Einführung.
Es gibt verschiedene Flugarten.
Das Auerhuhn
fliegt anders als ein Fasan.
Sie können die Teller
auf verschiedene Arten wegwerfen,
wie ein Auerhahn
oder ein Fasan fliegt.
Ich hätte am liebsten
eine Schildkröte.
Meine Königsdisziplin
am Schluss ist:
Wir jagen Jonny den Hang hinauf.
Hast du gehört?
- Was?
Das du mit der roten Jacke hinauf
rennst. Zick, zack, zick, zack!
Am Schluss schiessen wir
verschiedene Arten
und dann geht es darum,
wer mehr trifft.
Dann kennen wir den Tageschef.
Ready? Go!
Ups, das war gar nichts.
Da hat der Fischer Freude.
Ready? Pull!
Zweiter Schuss ein Treffer -
so läuft das.
Das er so schnell trifft,
hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ready? Pull!
Yes! A broken target.
The target came out broken
and he hit it.
That's two points for that.
Because it's broken.
Oh, because ...
- Yes, it spread out.
One target hit the crew,
and the other one ...
Es ist mir fast etwas peinlich.
Ich habe mich so gefreut, etwas
zu machen, das ich noch nie machte
und dann geht es nicht.
Das wäre schade. Aber irgendwie
hat es sehr gut geklappt.
I'am going ...
- Es ist jetzt leer.
Hey, Jungs, hört kurz zu!
Jetzt schiesse ich dann.
Ihr müsst auf die Seite gehen!
Sorry, das Team hat es
nicht so lustig gefunden.
Jetzt schauen wir einmal,
wie Manu schiesst.
Ich bin immer für Competitions,
aber das ist ein geiles Feeling:
auf etwas zu schiessen,
das sich bewegt. Das ist krass.
Ready? Pull!
Das war nichts.
Ich bin sicher, dass es Manu stinkt,
dass ich so viel ...
Das bringt ihn unter Druck.
Ready? Pull!
Wieder nichts!
Should've killed it.
Make sure that you see
the gun on the target.
You went up, on
and you did it again.
You hesitated
and you carried on with ...
Uh, da bin ich
gegen Manu aber etwas fies.
Jetzt wird er mega locker.
Jetzt beginnt er zu blödeln.
Das würde ich auch machen.
Etwas blödeln
und in die Kamera lächeln.
Und natürlich sagen, dass das
für mich nicht wichtig ist.
Das ist so nicht wichtig.
Aber das Herz macht so.
So ein Arsch da hinten!
So ein Arsch!
Klar, wenn man solche Scheiss-
Competitions macht, wird man nervös.
Das habe ich gar nicht gerne habe.
Ich habe lieber den Fun.
Da ist einer etwas angepisst.
Das ist immer so,
wenn man zu zweit etwas macht.
Ready? Pull!
Good lad, good lad.
Weisst du, was mein Problem ist?
Vom Gewehrschiessen
hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich müsse das Teil auf dem Lauf
genau auf dem Target haben.
Das ist hier nicht nötig.
Nur eine Bewegung und dann knallen.
Ich bin ihm gefolgt
und weil ich nicht ganz drauf war,
bin ich ihm noch weiter gefolgt.
Das hört sich an,
wie wenn jemand beim Super-G
mit dem rechten Ski hängen bleibt
und dann Erklärungen abgibt.
"Ich habe alles richtig gemacht."
"Der Aussenski rutschte mir weg
und darum bin ich hängen geblieben."
"Das passiert mir sonst
eigentlich nicht."
"Der Aussenski
ist mir weggerutscht."
So sprechen Verlierer.
Es ist wirklich das,
was ich vorher erklärt habe.
Es lief mir dann doch noch gut,
aber der Wettkampf gab zu reden.
Ich wurde nämlich wirklich stinkig.
Schade, sind wir beide in dieses
komische Wettkampffieber gekommen.
Ja, die Challenge-Sache ...
Ich bin
ein absoluter Harmonie-Junkie
Ich messe mich nicht gerne.
Ich bin ein Stück weit nicht
wettbewerbsfähig, vom Charakter her,
wobei ich diese Charakterschwäche
gut akzeptieren kann.
Ich verstehe Manu absolut.
Ich muss das mit ihm
noch einmal besprechen,
weil ich weiss,
dass etwas das mega schlimm ist ...
Das finde ich aber
in einer Partnerschaft auch.
Aber das ist auch
eine Art Partnerschaft.
Wenn man sich zu messen beginnt,
wird es schwierig.
Und ich weiss, dass das bei uns nie
geht. Wir haben dann immer Streit.
Schon seit Jahren versuche ich
Harmonie aufrecht zu erhalten,
denn Harmonie
braucht es für unseren Job.
Wenn es die nicht mehr gibt,
können wir den Job nicht machen.
Darum bemühe ich mich Harmonie
aufrechtzuerhalten.
Es geht so weit, dass ich nicht mehr
um den Tageschef kämpfen will,
sondern ihn aufteilen.
Das sind bad wipes und die
müssen wir nicht extra machen,
weil wir hier sind,
um unsere Freundschaft zu stärken.
I love it, I love it!
Das Problem ist erledigt.
- Und wir hatten echt wieder fun.
It's a beautiful shot.
Yeah, spirit! You got it.
So geil!
Es ist so etwas Schönes.
Wir haben wieder
am gleichen Seil gezogen.
Aber
in unterschiedlichen Richtungen.
* "Nellie The Elephant"
von Toy Dolls *
Tonight we're gonna be
real scottish.
It's only the kilt we miss.
Einen Kilt,
die schottische Nationaltracht,
hat man uns für den Abend
in Aussicht gestellt.
Wir haben es nicht genau verstanden,
aber Fergus hat etwas
von einem Haggis-Ritual erzählt.
Es wurde ein sehr spezieller Abend.
Wir haben die schottische Tracht
bekommen: den Kilt.
Wir haben uns den halben Tag
auf den Kilt gefreut.
Wir haben jetzt auch etwas bekommen.
Aber beim Anfassen,
haben wir gemerkt,
dass es ein normales Badetuch ist.
Das passt auf diese Farm.
Ein riesen Tamtam war das.
Unser Traum war doch,
einmal einen Kilt zu tragen.
Sie sagten, dass wir
sicher nicht den Mut hätten,
die Unterhosen auszuziehen.
Und jetzt bekommen wir ein Badetuch.
Sie sagten, es kämen
noch zehn Leute im richtigen Kilt.
Und wir müssen im Badetuch
mit den Leuten feiern.
Nein, also in einem Badetuch!
Sie haben
auch noch einen Hut organisiert.
Das ist aber eine billige Perücke,
die sie daran klebten.
Ich würde mich damit
an der Fasnacht schämen.
Ich muss noch den Gurt anziehen.
Da waren wir enttäuscht.
Es ist eine neues Gefühl unter dem
Badetuch die Unterhosen auszuziehen.
Ich bin ganz nervös.
Ich habe schon lange voraus gesagt,
dass ich einmal
einen Kilt anziehen möchte.
Aber kein Badetuch!
Ich finde, der Hut
steht dir besonders gut.
Du musst aber die Hosen
und alles aauziehen.
Wenn die uns in den ...
Sehe ich auch so Scheisse aus?
Du hast richtige rote Haare.
Ja, du siehst auch Scheisse aus.
Jetzt habe ich
trotzdem noch etwas Freude.
Aber warum eine so billige Kluft.
Es hiess für ein Haggis-Ritual.
Kennt Ihr Haggis?
Es ist
das schottische Nationalgericht,
gehackte Schafsinnereien,
serviert im Schafsmagen.
Diese Delikatesse
serviert Fergus auf seinem Tablett.
Wir hatten keine Ahnung,
was hier vor sich geht.
(Lachend) Aber locker mitgemacht.
Fair fa' your honest, sonsie face,
great chieftain o' the pudding-race.
Aboon them a' yet tak your place,
painch, tripe, or thairm:
Weel are ye wordy o'a grace
as lang's my arm.
The groaning trencher
there ye fill ...
Was Gregor hier erzählt hat ...
... haben wir
bis heute nicht kapiert.
Ausser, dass man
das Haggis malträtieren muss.
... wi' ready sleight. Yah!
Ye Pow'rs,
wha mak mankind your care,
and dish them out
their bill o' fare.
Well done, boys.
Hauptsache mitmachen!
Das glaubt ihr vielleicht nicht,
aber Haggis ist sehr gut.
Wunderschön war,
wie sich das gewendet hat
mit dem Einlaufen in den Esssaal.
Wir wussten nicht, worauf wir uns
einlassen mit dem Dudelsack voraus.
Er hat neben uns
sein Theater durchgezogen.
Unsere Stimmung hat sich gewendet.
Wir haben gemerkt, dass wir
den Abend fliessen lassen können,
und er v.a. interessant wird.
Heute war ein Wahnsinnstag,
ein Up-and-Down-Tag
Wir haben heute Abend gedacht,
dass wir uns mit diesem Kostüm
total lächerlich machen würden.
Aber es hat alles gepasst.
Es war zwar alles etwas aufgesetzt,
aber es hat gepasst.
Wir haben hier hinein gepasst.
Es hat mir sehr gefallen.
* Fröhliche, schottische Musik *
Burki kann bedeutend
besser tanzen als ich.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Kaum aufgestanden, ging es mit dem
Mike-Express zurück nach Inversnaid.
Dort, wo wir vor zwei Tagen
unseren Wanderweg verlassen haben.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Voll geil Mike, Tausend Dank.
In diesen zwei Tagen haben wir
mega viele Sachen erlebt.
Es waren sehr intensive Tage.
Jetzt freue ich mich,
wenn das Wetter so bleibt,
dass wir wieder
zurück in den Marschtrott kommen.
Der Blick auf die Karte zeigt, dass
wir noch ein Stück vor uns haben.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass es nun weitergeht.
Wir müssen ans Ziel kommen.
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von Sleeping at Last *
* Sanfte, getragene Musik
und Gesang *
Und da laufen wir wieder. Wir haben
es schon fast ein wenig vermisst.
Besonders wegen dem Zoff beim Ton-
taubenschiessen wegen dem Tageschef.
Wir haben das nachts noch geklärt.
Am Anfang dachten wir ja, der
Tageschef sei eine Erleichterung.
Und dann haben wir gemerkt,
dass Manu den Tageschef
eigentlich nicht richtig macht.
Und ich hänge sehr den Chef raus.
Damit mache ich mich zum Affen.
Vom Chef zum Affen.
Nein, ich mache das doch nicht.
Ich gebe doch Manu keine Befehle.
Das wäre vielleicht lustig,
aber ich mache das nicht.
Das wäre nicht deine Art.
Jetzt haben wir gemerkt, dass es
nicht schlecht ist,
wenn einer bei Entscheidungen
den Lead hat.
Es geht ja nicht
um König und Untertan,
sondern dass der Tageschef sagt,
wann wir Pause machen
und wann wir weitergehen.
Und äh ...
Ich glaube, so stimmt das
für uns beide. Nicht wahr?
Ja.
Jetzt haben wir es ausdiskutiert.
- Ja, jetzt ist es wieder gut.
# Wir haben keinen Streit mehr
wegen dem Tageschef.
# Nein, nein, nein!
Naja, das sieht jetzt
etwas peinlich aus.
Aber alles war bereinigt.
Wenn wir jetzt mit dem Zeug
hinuntergefallen wären.
Dann hättet ihr Freude, so wie bei
meiner Thermosflasche auf dem See!
Unser Tagesziel ist Ardlui
am Ende des Loch Lomond,
auf der anderen Seeseite.
Zu Fuss etwa 8 km.
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von Sleeping at Last *
* Sanfte, getragene Musik
und Gesang *
Es ist wieder einmal mehr typisch.
Man denkt, man sei bald am Ziel.
Einmal mehr: der letzte Kilometer
hört und hört und hört nicht auf.
Dort ist Ardlui.
Dort hat es einen Ballon,
den man hochziehen muss.
So sieht der Fährmann
auf der anderen Seeseite,
dass man abgeholt werden will.
* Jonny ahmt
den Fahnenmarsch nach. *
* Rasante, schottische Musik *
Ich habe etwas auf die Übernachtung
im Hotel gedrängt.
Ich brauchte unbedingt
wieder einmal Internetzugang.
Ich musste für Manus Geburtstag
noch etwas organisieren.
Erste Handwäsche.
Ich musste waschen und ich glaube,
auch der Körperhygiene
tut es wieder einmal gut
einfach in ein Schaumbad liegen.
Ich bin happy wieder einmal
in einem Hotel zu sein,
mit Badewanne oder Dusche.
Ich freue mich.
Buh, das stinkt!
Schau dir das Wasser an!
Ich weiss nicht,
wie lange man das machen muss.
Endlich Internet.
Am nächsten Tag hat Manu Geburtstag.
Als Geschenk habe ich hinter
seinem Rücken organisiert,
dass seine Frau uns besuchen kommt.
Ja, hallo, ihr Wanderer!
- Hoi, Mischi!
Hast du deinen Mann schon gehört?
Nur kurz. Er hat mir
zwei Bilder geschickt.
Ich habe für die nächste Nacht
an unserem Etappenziel
ein Hotel gebucht.
Jetzt musste ich nur noch schauen,
dass Michele dorthin kommt,
ohne dass Manu etwas davon merkt.
Einfacher gesagt, als gemacht.
Super! Ich freue mich.
Es ist cool, dass du mitmachst.
Es ist ein grosser Aufwand
für die paar Stunden.
Das ist cool.
Das glaube ich auch.
Und er ahnt überhaupt nichts.
Das Einzige, das ich wusste, war,
dass am Vorabend
meines Geburtstags Halloween ist.
Und, dass es in einem Pub nebenan
eine legendäre Party geben soll.
* Gruselige Musik *
Für den Schotten ist Halloween
wie für den Luzerner die Fasnacht.
Halloween hat hier
einen anderen Stellenwert.
Bei uns ist Halloween
erst im Kommen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Eigentlich waren wir
nicht so in Partystimmung.
Mal schauen, ob wir hier in meinen
Geburtstag feiern oder früher gehen.
Es ist anders gekommen.
* Rasante, schottische Musik. *
Und da hat
der Geburtstag von Manu angefangen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Nach 4 Std. Schlaf ging es
bei prächtigem Wetter weiter.
Ich durfte einen sehr
unvergesslichen Geburtstag feiern.
So schnell
werde ich das nicht mehr haben.
Ich werde es aber auch im Kreise
der Familie wieder geniessen.
Aber Burki,
dein Geburtstag hat erst angefangen.
Da kommt dann schon noch etwas.
* "Miserable Strangers"
von King Creosote *
* Idyllische Musik *
# It's my birthday,
It's my birthday!
See you next time. Thanks.
- See you next time..
* "Miserable Strangers"
von King Creosote *
* Idyllische Musik *
Es ist auch geil,
wenn wir sagen können,
dass es nur an deinem Geburtstag
schönes Wetter war.
Dieses Wetter ist wirklich
ein Geburtstagsgeschenk.
Ein letzter Blick
auf den Loch Lomond.
Von hier aus tauchen wir ein in die
Highlands, das schottische Hochland.
Das Tagesziel Crianlarich
habe ich heute festgesetzt.
Ich habe Michele dort hinbestellt.
14 km nach dieser
feuchtfröhlichen Nacht - boah!
Kann ich dir eine Cola bringen?
Ja, gerne.
Endlich ein Moment ohne Manu
und mit Empfang!
Sie ist hier.
Sie sitzt jetzt im Zug.
Blöd war heute Morgen,
dass Manu wegen seinem Geburtstag
sechsmal versuchte, sie anzurufen.
Sie schrieb mir immer,
ich solle ihn ablenken.
Dann tat sie so, als ob
ihr Natel nicht funktionierte.
Sie schrieb,
dass sie am Abend anrufe,
sie müsse das Handy herunterfahren.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Wahnsinn, wenn ich gewusst hätte,
dass meine Frau in diesem Zug sitzt!
Wir liefen nämlich
neben dem Bahngleis her.
Es ist eigentlich
immer noch wie im Engadin.
Ich fühle mich langsam wohler.
Es ist etwas hügeliger, bergiger,
steiniger. Das freut mich.
Und das ich das an meinem Geburtstag
an einem so wunderschönen Tag
erleben darf - I really appreciate.
Da sind sie: meine Highlands.
Und die letzten Kilometer
vor Crianlarich - echt wunderschön!
Ja, und die ist auch noch schön.
(Michele) Ich freue mich riesig.
Jetzt ist er
mehr als zehn Tage lang fort.
Ich glaube, so lange
waren wir noch nie getrennt.
Wir hören uns ja auch nur spärlich.
Er hat oft kein Netz,
keinen Empfang.
Daher weiss ich gar nicht,
wie es ihm geht.
Ich habe schon ein paar Mal
versucht, Manu zu überraschen.
Er hat immer etwas geahnt.
Jetzt glaube ich, ...
... weiss er wirklich nichts.
Ja, mein Schatzerl,
ich habe echt nichts geahnt.
Und das nächste Mal sehen wir,
wie meine Überraschung geglückt ist.
Nein, nein! Spinnt ihr eigentlich?
Und nackt ist es weitergegangen.
Es gab Siegeszigarren
und heisse Nächte.
Und Ausflüge der anderen Art
ins Nirgendwo.
Ich hatte zu beissen.
Ich hatte Respekt, ob wir es
körperlich schaffen mit dem Rucksack
bei diesem Wetter
154 km quer durch die Wildnis.
Uah!
Das und noch viel mehr
gibt es in der nächsten Folge
von "SRF bi de Lüt - Durch dick ...
... und dünn".
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Liz Lei - 2016